Ladders in machine knitting simply
means keeping needles out of work.
You can see that the working yarn is
traveling across that empty space and
creating a column of holes or ladders.
A common use for ladders is mock ribbing.
The ladder gives the appearance
of a purl stitch.
Mock ribbing is a great alternative
to using a ribber or hand manipulating
purl stitches to create ribbing.
Needles out of work can also be used
on each side of cables. Again giving
the appearance of a purl stitch.
Threading, ribbons, cords,
or even i-cord up that ladder can add
a decorative touch to your knitting.
For an easy, vertical turning row,
leave a needle out of work.
And
when you fold the knitting,
you'll have a sharp edge.
You might use this for a
vertical band or a facing,
for example. Just leave
a needle lot of work.
I hope you'll investigate ladders
and see how they can be a put
to use for your knitting projects.